trong trường trung à phổ thông và tháng,
môi trường này cũng là môi trường
tốt bà của thành phố đàn nè.
Tôi ở lại yêu cầu các em,
đi tính,
thái lại lượng,
lại lượng thứ nhất,
là bình phát tri của điện trọng L'err.
L'err,
lại lượng thứ này
là đi tính xai số tỉnh đối của điện trọng.
Bảo,
lợt phải mới lợt thái trọng chúng ta rạc tuôi khiến
lý推 thái có rung dất của em,
cách đi cái của đó.
Y nghĩa,
cái của các phát đồ được đi như sau,
ăn mạnh,
giá chị,
trung quên,
của các của đó,
cậu trường,
xai số tỉnh đối của phát đồ,
là đàn tà,
em đối chíu,
em thấy,
nhớ biết thế,
không có người đàn khi thế này,
không đồ rằng mẹ í người ta gí thế này,
thế trung mạnh,
vành tán vô,
đồ rằng mẹ,
trung mạnh,
có giá chị,
muốn ăn bè,
bà nào mà không biết gì,
bây giờ hỏi thần thái chị của biết,
tẹ chờ em rờ sẽ được tính bà,
uống trên ý,
uống ở vãi dụ,
uống,
bằng tà,
tà này,
chí rất cơ tồ rằng mẹ í,
bằng bột,
bài,
bằng hài,
ổ,
bây giờ em nghĩ cái xai số tỉnh đối,
bột cái điện chẳng,
lạv này,
tìm cái em phải điện xai số tỉnh đối,
tìm mà không tự tà.